So once again, we have a claim that there
are Republican senators willing, ready or
interested in convicting Donald Trump in the
expected impeachment trial in the United States
Senate.
Now, we had a story a week or two ago, uh,
that, uh, had a democratic Senator Chris Murphy
saying that there are Republican senators.
He says you can count them on one hand, but
that there are Republican senators who are,
uh, ready to convict Donald Trump in the Senate.
There was really no evidence of this.
It was just Chris Murphy saying that that's
what he believes.
We have another person saying this, but this
time it is a Republican, not a Democrat.
It's bill weld, former Republican governor
of Massachusetts who is also running, I guess
in some technical sense, although it's not
going anywhere.
A primary campaign against Donald Trump.
Bill weld was interviewed by the Hill and
he said, quote, I know most of the senior
Republicans in the Senate, they're picking
their words carefully when they talk to me
of all people, even though we are friends,
I wouldn't want to get quoted.
I don't even like to ask someone to do something
which is not in their political self-interest.
But yeah, I would say they're four to six
votes for removal right now.
So there are two responses to this.
Number one is no way, and number two is, so
what?
And I'll explain each of those responses.
First of all, there's no evidence right now
that there are really four to six Republican
senators ready to convict Donald Trump on
impeachment in the Senate.
Every indication we have so far is that they
will go against impeachment Republicans in
the Senate.
Will, you might even see a centrist Democrat
like Joe mansion also go against impeachment
in the Senate.
But can we come up with a list that is at
least circumstantially reasonable of Republicans
that might vote to convict Donald Trump?
Sure.
We talked about it last week.
Susan Collins in Maine, often a candidate
has been an occasional critic of Trump, but
the caveat is in the end she'll say a lot
of things, but in the end she'll get in line
like she did with Brett Kavanaugh and his
confirmation to the Supreme court.
Mitt Romney, Senator from Utah.
Mitt Romney has had many public disagreements
with Donald Trump.
They've had very acute, uh, um, uh, bad blood
between them.
I guess I would say it's conceivable.
Mitt Romney might say he would impeach, but
previously when asked, he has not given any
indication that he would Lisa Murkowski from
Alaska, her name always comes up anytime they
say, well, here's a more reasonable Republican
who might depart from Republican orthodoxy.
Her name is mentioned Cory Gardner.
There's a couple of others.
But as I said before, this is where we go
from no way to, so what, even in four to six
Republicans vote to convict Trump.
It won't remove Trump and it will get those
Republicans ostracized by the Republican party.
Because remember, you need two thirds of the
Senate, that's 67 senators to vote to convict.
In order to remove the president, there are
45 Democrats and to independence that caucus
with the Democrats, that means you need to
find 20 Republicans.
If you have maybe four to six you don't have
the numbers.
Now, the argument would be in order to be
thorough here, the argument would be if there
are already four to six Republicans and we
haven't even had a trial, there could be more
coming.
There could be momentum.
The best path to making removal of Trump or
reality is something that's not going to happen,
which is if the Senate passes a measure to
make, make impeachment votes a secret ballot
where they vote privately instead of publicly.
This way you could have exactly 20 Republicans
vote to impeach.
It would get Trump removed, but no one would
initially know which were the 20 that voted
to convict.
But again, there is no indication that there
exists a political appetite for this and the
Republican party.
And the question also is, could such a measure
even be passed with Mitch McConnell running
the show in the Senate as majority leader,
given that he says the white house will be
in total coordination with him as to how the
Senate trial would be run.
Certainly the white house would know that
a secret ballot would not be advantageous
to Donald Trump because it would allow some
Republicans, uh, to vote to convict without
suffering the political consequences and the
wrath of Trump as a result.
Very difficult to imagine that Mitch McConnell
even lets that be a serious discussion.
That's what we know so far.
Tell me what you think.
Agree, disagree.
If you're watching on YouTube, leave a comment
of course after hitting, like and subscribe
if you're watching or listening anywhere else,
send me a tweet at D Pacman and I believe
we will have a followup story about this on
the David Pakman show
Instagram, which you can find@thedavidpakmanshowoninstagramafterthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com